philippe edmond-mariette bonjour
bonjour à vous bonjour à l'ensemble des
auditrices et auditeurs de martinique la
première alors vous êtes candidat le
candidat du grand ensemble et pour ma
technique dans le centre la première
c'est conscription qu'est ce qui m'a
manqué ce qui a motivé votre candidature
je dois avouer qu'il y a la forte
volonté de voix que la martinique mon
pays se modifier à la froid en
profondeur au niveau de son
développement mais surtout parce que
j'ai beaucoup entendu le cri des jeunes
s'étaient déjà d'ailleurs l'une des
raisons de mon engagement politique à la
base mais s'est encore renforcée par la
situation que nous vivons actuellement
est il me fait dire que la martinique
est véritablement un tournant historique
surtout après le double scrutin
présidentiel que nous venons de
connaître ce sont des résultats qui
certes interpelle quant à la
maltraitance
gouvernementale de ces dernières années
mais singulièrement aussi par rapport au
combat politique qu'il nous faut
aujourd'hui mener à la martinique en
parfaite cohésion avec d'autres
populations et ce sont des résultats que
vous avez toujours en tête qu'on vous
mener campagne
oui parce qu'il est important de ne pas
être que déconnecté ni de la réalité ni
non plus être copé loigné des nécessités
des urgences de la martinique
d'aujourd'hui alors
17 candidats dans sur cette
circonscription quel est votre état
d'esprit comment vous abordez de sayyaf
les taureaux de candidats c'est sur
cette circonscription qui a le plus de
candidats l'oeil alors moi je me dis
qu'il peut y avoir plusieurs raisons à
ça est ce le fait que la députée
sortante ne se soient pas représentés
encore que elle se retrouve suppléante
après avoir annoncé qu'elle voulait être
que libérée de tout mais c'est son
affaire personnelle c'est aux électeurs
de se prononcer dessus et pas à moi
ensuite parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup se rendent
compte que la martinique a besoin de
renouveau que la martinique a besoin de
changement et puis que chacun se dit ben
je peux contribuer je peux apporter ma
pierre toutefois j'ai quand même un
regard plus acéré si vous le faites que
on peut pas faire de la politique
hors des partis et les fondamental que
ce soit quelque chose de collectif est
plus que jamais se présenter à des
législatives ça ne peut pas être une
aventure individuelle on a absolument
besoin que ce soit une aventure
collective parce qu'on représente pas
seulement sa petite personne mais on
représente un groupe politique on
représente une tendance on représente
une partie de la population si ce n'est
une fois qu'on est élu la population
dans son ensemble et je me dis que
quelque part ça peut être sur le plan
démocratique une bonne chose parce que
ça montre une certaine vitalité mais au
niveau du débat au niveau des idées ça
peut aussi nous tirer vers le bas
quels sont les grands thèmes que vous
développez pendant votre campagne alors
j'aime bien votre question parce que des
fois on vous demande quel est votre
programme un candidat aux législatives
n'a pas de programme les grands thèmes
pour moi sont des questions qui touchent
aux urgences martiniquaise
la première est sur ma circonscription
c'est le problème des sargasses la
seconde question c'est celle du scandale
du chlordécone c'est un combat que j'ai
commencé à mener depuis 2003 rappelez
vous même si la mission d'information
avait ses limites
mais c'était déjà un sujet sur lequel
j'avais été amenés à travailler avec
d'autres ensuite on à la question de
l'abrogation de la loi de mai 2021 qui
est ce texte qui est venue fragiliser
nos soignants des infirmiers des aides
soignantes et cetera ceux qui
travaillent dans les ehpad des sapeurs
pompiers il faut aujourd'hui à oui
absolument moi je suis tout à fait pour
qu'il soit réintégré on s'est bien rendu
compte que ce qu'une loi peut faire une
autre loi peut le défaire avec salaire
et attractivité trop activités sur les
salaires et les trois activités écoutez
c'était dans le programme 2011 dont il a
été le premier au soir du premier tour
des présidentielles
au second tour c'était marine le pen est
elle aussi elle préconisait déjà cela
alors sans doute faut-il le faire en
concertation avec
les différents établissements publics de
santé qui sont amenés à recevoir ces
personnels là mais aujourd'hui on a une
vraie crise des moyens humains dans le
grand centre de santé les hôpitaux les
ehpad et c est tout pour moi c'est une
urgence et une nécessité à la fois en
matière de santé mais sur le plan social
où allez vous siégez si vous êtes élu
alors pour l'instant nous n'avons pas
déterminé de positionnement d'abord nous
voulons connaître la couleur définitive
de la majorité parlementaire au soir du
18 juin nous aux grands ensembles et
aucun d'entre nous n'ira siéger sur le
blé banc de la république en marche ou
de renaissance ou d'horizon du modem
notre position est très claire nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une opposition
constructive à ce que nous propose le
gouvernement
malgré ton sur les bancs de la gauche où
naturellement nous devrions nous
retrouver nous ne sommes pas prêts à
être sur des bancs pléthorique parce que
nous aurons besoin que notre voix soit
entendue quand vous êtes dans un groupe
de 180 ou de 200 parlementaires avec le
tourneau veur qui se fait on vous voit
pas souvent et donc notre philosophie
sur ça et de dire que sur les bancs de
la gauche il faut unir sans confondre
est distingué s'en séparer dernière
question en vain second qu'avez vous à
dire à la population et lecteurs de
votre circonscription ou qu'elles
puissent voter pour vous pour les
convaincre bien leur dire simplement
j'ai l'expérience pour occuper ce poste
et je souhaite simplement pour la
martinique comme pour tous nos enfants
le meilleur merci de votre confiance et
voter philippe edmond-mariette dès le 11
juin je répète mon mariage je vous
remercie c'est moi merci beaucoup bonne
fin de journée à vous tous
[Musique]